ouverte aux jurés ni bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
de milan ce matin avec nous sur rt
france on va parler de ceci peut-être
pas sanitaire qui entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui en italie il est aussi
l'ancien pas sanitaire qui est toujours
d'actualité
qu'est ce qu'il a de nouveau ce super
passe sanitaires alors superfast
sanitaires à des nouveaux les flics et
il est exclusivement réservée pour les
gens vaccinés au guéri donc ils
commencent à voir vraiment une
démarcation entre les gens qui sont pas
vaccinés et les gens qui se font
vacciner parce que jusqu'à maintenant
mais ne l'est pas vacciner il avait
accès aux mêmes
endroits travail et loisirs qu'elle est
non vaccinés à condition d'avoir un
résultat du test covit de négatif
aujourd'hui c'est les super passe
sanitaire qui permet si un cadet et
zokora vous aux jeunes orange aux gens
vaccinez d'accéder à tous les tours les
uns doit alors qu'elle n'est pas
vaccinée comment s'annonce des
restrictions à ce qu'ils peuvent accéder
ou 13 pour
commencer il est aussi encore une
polémique parce que c'est la question
qui va faire les contrôles et si on
s'est posé la question si interdire
l'accès aux traces portes au public pour
l'épauler mineurs qui entre 12 et 18 ans
qui ne sont pas vaccinés
très très disputé mais disons qu'ils
essaient aussi pour en laisser des
communes entre les plus réfractaires à
ces vacciner sas qui n'est pas vaccinée
pour beaucoup plus de limitations par
jean maxime et
les plus hauts et l'europe et pour le
monde c'est là où la troisième vague et
la cmq en bague et là il ya un secret
sur tellement de soucis au niveau des
derniers et tout ça cependant les
structures co vide qu'ils étaient
construits et toute urgence
la première vague et les minéraux
qu'ils allaient augmenter vous le disiez
un très fort taux de vaccination près de
85% des habitants âgés de plus de 12 ans
ont déjà reçu leurs deux injections
est-ce que la mise en place de ce super
passe sanitaire a eu un effet déjà sur
sur les demandes de vaccination ou alors
le reste il se trouve que ce sont des
réfractaires et qu'ils ne se feront pas
effectivement vaccinées
alors une toute petit sursaut et c'est
pas si flagrant comme moi quand il avait
la liste aux rations du premier grain
passe donc la la la la la cal pact
vaccinale qui déjà elle devrait
développement en italie a été boostée je
pense qu'en tout cas il y aura toujours
un
une partie des jeunes un facteur
dominant les des questions qui se posent
c'est le big lots biya et j'étais libre
excelle habituellement c'est une piste
il être si faut dire que les
réfractaires est bien parti aussi permis
mais
aussi les professions médicales par
rapport ce nouveau type de vaccin et
c'est la couverture vaccinale qui
finalement est très courte mais il ya
aussi de l'espoir et de la teinte pour
les vaccins plus classiques
par exemple celle du scénovision orevac
qui devait apparaître dans les mois qui
suivent donc je pense que tout le monde
la politique fait le choix des crises et
la
différence entre les vacciner nous
vacciner personnellement je suis pas sûr
qu'il soit l'ami meilleure façon de
diviser la population pour
arriver à la clé tout le monde parce que
de l'autre côté sacré vraiment déclin
d'un trait les vacciner le maximum
mais bon ça c'est des choix politiques
des points de vue médical effectivement
les difficultés c'est d'avoir réduit la
couverture vaccinale
au premi re temps on disait avec des
doses ont découvert sous un temps on est
passé avec moi et maintenant on parle
des six mois et il ya là deux boosters
donc effectivement l'espoir qu'ils
étaient mineurs ces vaccins pour traiter
pas de mine qu'ovide finalement elle
montre ses limites mais aussi avec les
variants on y connait tout ça
se laisse quelques doutes aussi de la
population à caractère aux vaccinations
on le sait très croyante en italie l
approche de noël vigilance particulière
par rapport au fait qu'ils arrivent
et oui disons qu'il est déjà un souvenir
de l'année dernière quand d'un pour
sauver le noël imprimés et jusqu'à 2 cp
rade parce qu'il faut savoir qu'ici
mittal y aussi cette semaine ses mails
même particulière à milan ce
spécifiquement des mails après des
médecins et des jours fériés de
l'arrivée d'alli mercredi si dur jour
férié et c'est toujours la salle de
macolin c'est l'âge où c'est là où on
commence vraiment à voir tous les
marchés de noël et on rentre dans les
calendriers de lalbenque donc les clés
d'un noël ils sont très différents c'est
le déclenchement de noël cette semaine
et l'année dernière il ces moments il y
avait une sorte des restrictions de pour
sauver noël cette année on est de ce
point de vue on est beaucoup plus au
sérieux on fait partir c'est super green
passe toujours pour ce degré
effectivement comme vous dites et
l'italie seul bémol c'est très important
à côté de ça les polémiques qui rien à
voir avec ovi dominant ces deux là d'un
utile qu'elle vienne d'état il faut plus
dire bommel pour des respects des autres
nous font dire bonne fête et ça aussi ça
fait grincer pas mal de soucis
effectivement c'est d'ailleurs ce que
préconise on l'a vu un document de la
commission européenne ce sera un autre
débat alors peut-être juste une ouest
quelques secondes juste avant de nous
quitter il ya eu ce cinquantenaire un
italien du piémont il a voulu obtenir le
pass annie terre il s'est fait vacciner
sur une prothèses en silicone il devra
en répondre devant la justice quel
retentissement cette affaire a eu en
italie mais là une grande couverture
médiatique
il faut dire qu'en plus c'était un
dentiste donc quelqu'un
sanitaires et bon forcément c'est les
novak ski qui sont obligés de voir parce
que travailler il faut dire que ni terry
en a mis l'obligation pour les
passionnés terre pour la vaccination
pour le personnel médical pour les
personnes et pour les enseignants et
poulets les policiers et par contre
effectivement il ya un an
cette polémique que l'effet moustique
est bon il a hélas et essayer de se
faire vacciner avec une prothèse alors
que forcément les infirmières
qui ont aperçu de suite du fait qu'ils
se c'était une prothèse
cep entre les faits divers la stabilité
et la provocation donc
maintenant lui il est avec les avocats
parce qu'il est clairement elle est très
médiatisée et je pense qu'il faut garder
souci par rapport à sa carrière
professionnelle
les années qui viennent effectivement
que prévisible
c'est rodez cabotage il ya aussi des
faux parce que sanitaires qu'ils étaient
trouvés sur des échanges télé carbone
dues à ce niveau là les écarts
merci beaucoup uberto giovannini de nous
avoir fait un point ce matin en direct
de milan